when did you decide all right this is
what I'm going to do I'm going to go out
on my own and I'm going to uh use uh you
know I'm going to use this Tech that I
have and my improvisational skills and
my wits and I'm going to make this
musical mashup of music comedy when does
that happen I mean that happened I think
when I was about
31 32 um I I was uh in my band mock tube
which was a really amazing band to be a
part of a great band um but we had been
I think we'd been together for 5 years
and we' gone through a bunch of hype
Cycles with labels and and like you know
execs coming out Jimmy iovan coming out
to watch us and like doing showcases in
LA and stuff like that Viper Room and it
would we'd almost almost something would
happen and then we'd go back to like ah
they passed or whatever and then we
would work on another record or
something like that and uh and I just
wasn't seeing it evolving Beyond you
know the third time that we'd gone
through that so um and I was doing
comedy and then I saw you know um uh
what are they called please uh Michael
shalter michaelan Black of the State
Wayne Uh not the state Stella yeah I was
Post State I I learned about State later
but I saw Stella and I was like what is
this those DV those little shorts shot
on DV Y and I was like this is my humor
these these guys know how meaningless
things are and like and and that's so
beautiful and so I ified with that and
then they ended up I think Wet Hot
American Summer came out yeah and I saw
that and I was like totally like oh
that's yes I want to do that you know I
was so driven and inspired by those
things and then they happened to come to
town uh Stella did come to town I met
Eugene Merman and I was introduced by a
friend and and he was like we have a
comedy night in New York you know and
then I ended up writing with a band and
they needed me in New York for the
writing session for a month so while I
was there I did a couple spots that
invite them up and in instant friends
with everybody it was like being in high
school again it was exactly I mean
whenever I get up on stage solo these
days I'm like this is what I was doing
in high school this is exactly the same
with a little bit more Tech it's
funny the uh I do feel like there's this
and it applies to everybody there's this
uh period of your life where you comp
feel completely isolated and alone and
then you're just so you're working on
your thing in complete anonymity and uh
then time goes by and you just keep
working on it and working on it and then
slowly you you know it's it's like any
of those movies where someone's off on a
journey and they pick up people along
the way do you know like some kind of
Hobbit tail or something but you're on
your journey and you pick up people and
then we're joined by this creature and
then this guy decides to come along and
then you know we meet this woman and she
comes along and you just build up this
troop and then finally you find kind of
of what the mission is but it comes much
later and I'm always trying to encourage
uh you know I I think there's sometimes
younger people feel this pressure to
know right away what it is and I think
you don't know yet you just keep working
on these instincts that you have and
this other stuff will come to you
because you haven't some time has to go
by this is just necessary it's that's
exactly right I mean when some of my
younger friends are younger artists are
like H you know how did you how do you
make it and you know how' you basically
that's like the the question but how do
you make it and I'm like well I don't
know you don't have to worry about
making it like what you have to make is
the thing that you love to do yes and do
that and more and most importantly find
the community like go out to the
Nights Watch people on the lineup don't
be backstage talking to everybody that's
nice you know once in a while of course
but like if you can see few people on
the lineup look at the look at what
they're doing and have fun laugh at it
don't be analyzing it just like have a
fun time laughing at it get involved in
the scene and be inspired that way and
then like oh yeah that was that was a
dumb idea oh what if you know and then
you make your stuff and you just follow
the fun and the fun leads you to
Opportunities you know I I I really
think it's that simple even though it
but it's hard to not be worried you know
because you might be like I'm taking a
little bit of a gamble or someone's like
I don't know if I'm going to make it at
this and those are okay thoughts but you
know I always tell people like if you
wake up in the morning and you can't not
thinking be thinking about a bit and if
you're always doing bits like that's
that's kind of what you are yeah you're
not going to change that so you might as
well make a career out of it no I I I
always maintained that I've my career is
me doing what I'd be doing anyway and
then I was fortunate to find some people
who had money who and and owned the
Machinery who were like well you can do
it for us uh but it
it it's the dirty little secret is that
if they said well we're done and we're
taking away all the equipment I'd say
okay well back to my bits
yeah here my old bits like just open up
this closet whatever and I would just do
it in in an empty field and I think uh
and and a you know whatever a passing
Dove would say that seems sad
um he's not aging well he sure isn't who
are you Mr turtle um well I didn't know
you could
talk everyone every this whole thing
about how they can't believe each other
can talk like but my bits but my bits
we're finding out we can talk and you're
obsessed with your bit Conan yeah but
but here's my bit about Ronald Reagan
you know well well well
well that's not interesting enough so
how did you learn to talk toad
stool
how could the toad stool not like my
Reagan
bit um my God you write in the book that
uh because I noticed that uh just in
tour that the uh women are quite taken
with Mr Reggie Watson then you you write
in the book that your your uh your dream
girl is Pippy long stalking oh me too
really g a huge crush on Inger Nelson
the original oh yeah yeah well also the
concept but yes she was great she was
great she was great
of it yes oh andg called stop writing
her letters well no but because of this
show they interviewed me for a pppy
documentary we talked about it on here
they sent me a signed uh vinyl with
Inger Tommy and anuka yeah wait who are
the other two Tommy and anuka okay can
you fill in just for people that are
listening and had some sort of a
childhood what people want to know who
the other two are Tommy and ANUK are
like her normal kid Sidekicks okay we
needed to know yeah they're friends
they're part of the crew yeah yeah yeah
but she's amazing she's she's amazing
she was super strong she had a basement
full of treasure so she had unlimited
funds she could travel anywhere she
could lift a horse she had she could
lift a horse she could you know she had
she was magical she had like you know
red hair I'm a half red head uh you know
I she she had she had pigtails that were
magical and like she had cool style I'm
having such a sense memory right now I'm
in my grandfather's small house in uh in
Misquamicut Rhode Island and there's a
Pippy long stalking movie that comes on
and this might have been with Inger and
it was and back then there's only three
channels this TV and Miss quut
Connecticut near the State Beach doesn't
get many of much reception of anything
so you'd see the same thing over and
over again and they were running a a a
commercial for the Pippy long stalking
movie and there was just one line that
rang in my head which is a weird
overdubbed someone I think overdubbing
yeah because it was Swedish her accent
would change from film to film she would
have just like a transatlantic and then
some films she'd just be like I'm from
Brooklyn I'm Pippy long stalking you
know well okay so what I remember you
tell me if this at all rings a bell is
she's lifting a horse she's running
super fast like 100 miles an hour and
they've just sped up her legs she's
doing all these crazy things and then
they just cut to a very European weird
kid and it looked like poor quality film
stock who goes Pippi are you crazy yeah
that's probably Tommy yeah yeah okay and
I remember seeing that and going what
the what kind of movie is this you sum
it up my grandfather a retired policeman
would say turn that crap
off Pippi are you
crazy wow but they're using clips from
this podcast in that documentary because
we talked about it that well we're going
to talk about it more now I know and um
where's my cut by the way I want a piece
of thaty money isy money give me that
long stocking I want in on that long
stocking money so what is it about Pippy
long sucking you first and then you Matt
what is it um I think
I I don't know I guess I like that she
was like fully independent you know like
she ran her own operation and she she
ran her own operation she just went on
adventures she was just like going on
adventures all the time cuz that's what
she was her grandfather was a pirate or
something her father was a pirate and
but no longer in the picture and then
you know and had like this gang of kids
and I don't know I just I had a huge
crush on her I thought that she was hot
that's cool yeah I mean I think Superman
was always the ideal when you were a kid
but pippy was kind of a little bit more
real istic her parent left her dad left
her alone just to live in this house
called Villa villaa and he just goes and
sails the Seas and I had a huge crush on
her too yeah I think she was maybe like
Blondie and pippy were my first two
crushes yeah Blondie was pretty amazing
yeah they're a little different but yeah
or you know what uh actually uh Dale
boio oh yeah whoin uh no no from missing
person that's right yeah uh woman she's
like yeah she looked like blond kind of
right she kind of well she kind of
looked like a cross between Blondie
people are going to kill me like a cross
and um and who's the dude from twisted's
Sister oh D Snider SN like a tiny bit
like a hair like like I have a huge
crush on D Sid there you go yeah that's
my ideal yeah no uh that's interesting
no Blondie hit really hit big my
freshman year of high school and I
remembered her just being the ideal like
oh that's the sexiest and she still is
yeah she for God's sake she's the most
she's the sexiest coolest woman alive we
need to get Blondie and pippy on this
podcast and have them fight yeah but
pippy would probably win she' start
beating Blondie and I'd go pippy are you
crazy 16
mm stored
improperly